you still a heavy smoker on the on the
on the ganja yeah papers only still
paper's only Still Still tells the game
until the day I die yes
you and Wiz are gonna run it back on the
joint The Joint side what's up Wiz let's
do it yeah he got his new album about to
drop off on there for sure what's it
called G uh G was it what the [ __ ] is it
called he's not even on Atlantic anymore
you guys wouldn't even [ __ ] know
deluxe edition I think just dropped of
Multiverse but he's got his other [ __ ] G
raw G Star G song you know what
[ __ ] you got me erase this part God damn
it I think we could just pull it out and
give him a nice plug because because
that's our brother and we love him it's
called G something
uh whiz we got a plug with his album man
we can't not do it yeah knowing him it's
probably nowhere on yeah there's no it's
got to be on his on his page I've been
seeing him
promoted yeah he's been promoting it but
he's not in the captions oh g-rage
g-rays see Rays all right I race up
until here so the new Wiz album G rage
man that's just gonna go crazy crazy